[Music]
good morning everyone and welcome to our
second day of deliberations we start
with submission points in the blue
folder pages 62 through 270 we've got
mr. Markham in mr. hat with us and to
provide clarifications or answers and
the apart of the surf required so we
start firstly on page 62
I wondered just in this answer and it
may well be another commentary Helene if
we could just expand on the benefits
that the council hears with enterprise
North Canterbury the statement of intent
just the it needs a bit more fleshing
out than the out so that's the and the
officer recommendation
you
she cares about is it in the okay does
anyone anyone in disagreement
yeah just just on that at the bottom
with film of their page it says the KC
do KTC be in this and in this commentary
talks about a lack of information the my
understanding is that the carpet or the
community borders as informed as the
counselors on what we're doing in the
space and I just thought I'd like that
in the response that I mean I'm not sure
with mr. Pinkins confused about his own
submission in the Kaipara
community boards or whether is confused
about what I'm not sure more year six
years across the page here I mean one of
the problems and I minimize will put it
out there one of the problems we have
with mr. Pinkins submission is that he's
at odds with the corporate community
board and it seems to get in the way of
some of the coincidence trying to make
some of the points of very good points
but I'm not quite sure whether he's
speaking on behalf of the community
board here or whether he's speaking on
behalf of himself this one seems to be
that he's speaking on behalf of any
would is not or shouldn't be it's an
individual here because we know that
there was crest Greengrass presented the
submission on behalf of the community
board point point made
that's very concern I wondered if as
well in the answer that you know there's
an inference and here that council
doesn't take climate change seriously I
think that statement needs to be made
very clear clearly we've appointed this
team of portfolio holder with
responsibility for climate change
there's a mayoral forum group that we're
involved is working which is referenced
here on the Canterbury climate change we
can group and we are working on a
connected approach between depart
on a climate change document recording
the progress in the we were it is a
record so that works underway so I think
that the answer needs to be fleshed out
to recall them Katherine and I think you
mister Mia I would echo those comments
on page 63 which deals with the same
issue
[Music]
it's a submission by an mr. Houseman and
he expresses displeasure at the lake of
meaningful action by the council
well I would express my displeasure with
paragraph 4 regarding electric vehicle
charges the council had a good debate on
that and I may have even moved the
motion I didn't at the time and I still
feel the same way he want the council to
incur the costs of providing a service
station for vehicles and I think the
council is moving forward in looking in
in providing a sight Thank You mr. Mia
we have provided or indicated we would
provide sites for electric vehicle
charging stations but we didn't go so
far as to say we would provide them at
the rate payers expense and I think it's
something that the private seat that can
deal with the council itself is moving
towards lower mission vehicle fleets
sure we haven't gone the full electric
vehicle way and there is a big cost
involved with it
so we've
on the hybrid way or were certainly
looking at their and I think low
emissions as a step in the right
direction so I think we have actually
made some progress and it's not going to
happen overnight it's going to take time
so I would like the answer and the
officer recommendations to be quite
strong and clear on the approach we're
taking thank you and you said also like
to note that the sustainability
champions within the organization and
the sustainability strategy in the
seminars that have been held in house
and to try and progress that however I
don't think that the outside of the
actual recommendation I am a little
confused about the progress we're making
and at perhaps that I would like to call
so at some point for a briefing on how
we're doing in the space because we do
get a lot of questions in the space
perhaps it would be also helpful if
missed it was referenced in the staff
level there's a working group with these
recommendations I think it would be very
helpful as part of that briefing I'd
like to know what the recommendations of
the staff working group her in for that
to be filled and so we are aware of
what's being recommended and we have a
greece's here and there look in a large
point I do agree with a few of the
things that Daniel has said in his
submission there are a lot of more
things that we can do however just with
regard to overall what we're doing in
that space regarding climate change in
general yes we all have an obligation to
do our bit but we as a council cannot
our actions alone aren't enough to stop
climate change not a global scale this
is an in-house thing what our policy is
is to get our own house in order so with
regard to mr. Pinkins submission on a
practical scale all we can do is either
accept risk mitigate risk or address
and with regard to sustainability we do
have the strategy coordination group and
with regard to including elected members
and in making what we're doing more
known Stage two of that strategy is
being developed right now and they are
talking about appointing elected members
from each of the community boards
sustainability champions to work on that
strategy so they will be included in the
future so I don't know if we're at a
point where we can put that in our reply
but I think that if you guys are happy
with where we're at with that that that
is a very good point to make to mr.
Pinkham and I think the moment but but
it is it is an in-house strategy it's
not us singing out to the world what
they should do and I think that that
should be echoed with all of these the
sustainability and climate change points
that have been made through all these
submissions that we need to get our own
house in order before we can tell
everybody else what we think they should
be doing so that's it for me thanks
extinct did you give us some points of
community board and hear about this
Enochs it's been wanting a station there
for quite some time effectually makes it
up but it's it's to be a private person
that puts a ton in we haven't really
heard anything more back from that so
obviously they were cheating to see how
how'd our feel was fearing before they
went went to put one and dot's and some
haven't heard any more about that takes
a good
point there was there's been a lot of
week that Vanessa Thompson's undertaken
we are we in Council resolution that
actually did approve that could go on
AirLand so I think that they should but
it was to explore a private partnership
is opposed to council putting then so
they should be put in the urals so can i
sorry sorry so there'll be a report to
Council in July on proposal that
proposals that have been received around
the charging stations Thank You mr.
mayor
just on the in-house sustainability
progress what is the mechanism for
reporting through to what committee and
can that happen on a regular basis
wherever it is so there'll be a report
to the council
next week on progress with the
sustainability strategy it would have
gone to audit and Risk Committee but
remembering that during a lockdown that
was not did not proceed it can it is it
proposed to happen on a regular basis
that it will come through to audit and
risk progress within in-house
initiatives so the proposal at the
moment and you need to give us guidance
as to whether you want more frequent
reporting but we will be reporting on
progress with the first-stage
sustainability strategy through order
and risk committee on a quarterly basis
so you'll get the full council will get
the quarterly report next week and we
have a program briefing I think it's the
end of June with you looking at the
scope and scale of the stage-two
strategy and
sort of actions that might be
appropriate now stage two is moving from
innocence service centre environment to
the wider organization in terms of what
we can do as an organization and all of
our range of activities and then stage
three is really then out to the
community but as mr. Muir highlighted
earlier our aim is to get ourselves also
the portfolio holder highlighted get
ourselves in order demonstrate some
progress as an organization and then and
then be able to engage with the
community about our experience as an
organization how we've affected and
sustainability to our way of working and
suchlike so that would be a progressive
roll out over this coming year subject
to you know ultimately there is a need
to invest in sustainability and how we
manage that investment and needs to be
carefully considered casas Joe I noticed
the submission of Daniel refers to
simple things like three been rubbish
recycling for the office still to make
the appearance and I did notice when we
had lunch in the air there what is the
difficulty because that was brought up
when Mike O'Connell came and presented
what's the difficulty was having a
rubbish separation organics it was in
this building because across the road at
the petrol station they have four bins
for separating out your rubbish from
there so what's the difficulty here so I
can't answer that specific question
now
via points their assignments got a good
handle on there as well super hips for
Simon he could work with Helene on a
better response and we can currently see
so because we've got a good we've got a
good message in that space more than
what we reflected here right so page 65
I think the same could be incorporated
into this one page 66 in the answer I
don't think it's necessary to say
there's no hierarchy of community
outcomes because it's just talking about
us refreshing them so therefore I really
felt that that statement wasn't actually
beneficial to the commitment it's
actually a separate issue and where's
the what the submitter was asking she's
actually asking something completely
different she's asking for a split in
the Heritage Fund and the indigenous
fauna fund that we shouldn't have
buildings in fauna together which is
something I'd raised previously so
that's not actually answering your
question it's a fear commie
and it would be a measure for falls
under deep you know they that they
consideration be given it was discussed
last tune but his have been discussed as
to him so I think a fear response would
be the council asked this DP and our
committee to reconsider that point right
the statement that the district clear
notification will occur at least after
level one we don't know what level will
be it when the notification occurs we're
hoping it'll be little one but just be a
little cautious
your budget so I'm probably your easiest
presentation to probably easier than
some of the other managers are paid so
go now while you've got it well sorry
[Laughter]
thank
we're now at this page 71 which is one
submission attributed to me strangely
enough but it says about 5g rollout so
anything I'm just suggest editing and
here is the Prime Minister science
adviser has reviewed the Syria and there
is some recommendations that that they
head in in terms of reviewing this so I
think it would be with inserting that
reporter for those public and those
findings because they did look at 5g
quite considerably through and Prime
Minister science adviser it was a
specific task that was reported to rural
and provincial a couple of months being
through any other feedback there okay
all right
it's we're onto yeah six point one four
pages one seven five to 185 say chief
and mr. war mr. mill with him mr. Warren
in your hands good morning smearing
councillors this report and
recommendation covers both the
refurbishment of the ring or a service
centre in the future planning of the
broader Civic precinct with regard to
the refurbishment Council will recall in
February there was an approval for a
core refurbishment with a budget of 4.8
million staff have reviewed the project
and are recommending a reduced scope of
works that will enable deferral of a
number of elements of the refurbishment
and reduced the overall budget to 1.5
million this is in response to the need
for moderate moderation where possible
and with the financial burden placed on
the community Duty Cove at 19 the
revised scope will address the key
issues of performance in the building
and particularly the heating and
ventilation system the quality of some
weak spaces in a Paschal replacement of
damaged ceilings tales
carpets throughout in replacement of
light fittings also included as an
upgrade of the audio-visual system and
furniture in the chambers it excludes a
full replacement of the heating and
ventilation system electrical systems in
lighting and IT networks bathrooms in
major reconfiguration of internal
layouts that was originally anticipated
but it will also improve some natural
light in efficiency of space also
through this although this will not
deliver all of the benefits of the core
refurbishment it will restore a better
working environment for staff and
visitors and allow deferral of the
larger refurbished works until the
councillors in a better position to
understand the needs of the organization
the second part of the report addresses
the plan to advance work on development
of the long term plan for the Civic
precinct
this was also a decision that council
made in February and is a major project
within the draft ring euro town centre
strategy in order to stage the work to
match the immediate needs regarding
economic recovery and long term plan
development the initial focus is
proposed to better understand the
development scenarios which may be
stimulate economic activity in the Civic
needs subsequent phases will complete a
master plan an implementation program a
budget of 200,000 is recommended for
this first phase as per your February
decision this is proposed to be overseen
by a steering group comprising of a mix
of senior staff and counselors and
counsel are invited to appoint three
members to this group and the staff
suggest that the mere ex-officio in
Council award as portfolio holder are
two of the members the draft terms of
reference are attached to the report as
an addition to the terms of reference it
is also recommended that the strategy
group provide oversight to the
refurbishment project and in particular
decisions made in regard to chambers and
public spaces this would be an
additional resolution to ed to the role
defined in the terms of reference this
week is expected to take five to six
months MB
able to inform the long-term plan
process just just that the this project
has been reduced back from the four
point eight million in relation to the
covert nineteen and the economic fallout
we were expecting as to make sure that
we are cutting the cloth as two point
and doing the via minimum the HVAC
system is is well beyond its replacement
period it's difficult to hold
temperature up in the winter and in the
summer is just absolutely getting to the
point where it's ridiculous
so it's we've looked at doing the bare
minimum just to make sure that we're
trying to keep within budget and make
sure the staff have a reasonable working
environment it's a five-year term which
we're looking at wholly or for and the
second part of that proposal was to form
a group involving counselors to look at
the whole site in what should be here
and how it links in with the regular
Town Center and businesses for future
there's any questions councillor Stewart
front of my council Bannon thank you
this is very lightweight we should the
met of the Civic precinct which is
appended to this this report why don't
we actually put the Civic precinct
around the whole block and because there
enables I don't know what the future
will bring but we're presuming that
there will be a contraction of services
I guess but that doesn't necessarily
mean well the contract the contraction
of the space needed here but that
doesn't necessarily mean that in fact
you will have
yes local body services provided from
this precinct that may be that you're
you're doing sheared stuff and there is
a base here so why don't infect you do
the block because we've we only actually
building in front of that we obviously
don't own a bill but who knows and so
why don't you take a wider perspective
of the spatial area here and put that
civic precinct ground the whole bit I
mean you've got the old courthouse in
there there are shows yeah there is why
not you know look I think them to some
degree this comes down to semantics in
town planning purposes you might argue
they're a wider block is as appropriate
and I'm not fully qualified to to talk
to the town center strategy yes I didn't
I say that and the extent of it from an
active management perspective which was
where we have been coming in and
presenting this report it's it was more
targeted on what we do with those land
holdings that we definitively own but I
think the point is quite a relevant one
if in fact there are some potential
opportunities or ways of enhancing the
wider and public amenity space then
there is something there could well be
considered I would suggest that it might
be something that the steering group may
subsequently bring back to Council but
at the moment we've limited ourselves to
looking at the area there isn't a direct
control as opposed to implying there
could be taken from this by property
owners else outside of that that somehow
we are suggesting that we are moving
into this space somehow and so I think
there's a we just need to traverse there
carefully so we avoid any conflict with
private property owners
it's just looking at 4.20 which is your
do minimum to address the poor
performance of the building and and it
talks about the replacement of the
chambers audio-visual system will there
being some IT changes needed to support
that to actually enable that to happen
and is that included in the budget we do
actually have Rob Kerr who's our project
director and on a zoom with us today and
I'm hoping that he's interactive it's
probably better if I point that question
and Rob his direction and so that he can
talk through that Rob Dunn relatively
interactive today so the we've made an
allowance for the AV we haven't looked
at it in detail enough to know what
network changes might be required to
ensure that you've got the speeds that
you need but send me the information
that I know is that if there is it
should be relatively modest sum but
that's obviously it will be part of the
that design process to ensure that all
that all our capability and capacity in
the system's the supplementary question
to mr. Moore would because he's in
charge of the IT area and will we be
looking with potential need for more
zoom and so on going forward
will there be a review of the IT
department budget is to our needs for
the future yeah that that sounds it's a
good question as we've experienced in
the room in the last couple of days
Wi-Fi and connection isn't up to
standard
but the wiring is allowed for in the IT
budget to rewire the building so that's
taken care of whatever we do we need to
make sure that we future-proof and so
that'll be part of their the work that
we undertake question
so one of the Rob's probably when we
when we had the big scheme running at
five mil or whatever and one of the
drivers for that for us approving it was
the weight of the roof the unsuitability
of the roof from a earthquake risk point
of view by I'm while I'm supportive of
Bo and then the reduced plan are we okay
with with compliance factors and safety
and in walking away from our heavy roof
the game Rob may wish to add to this so
please feel free to jump in Rob that the
scheme is we have it hasn't got any
substantial works allowed for with the
roof we have explored a few avenues in
relation to certain particular targeted
areas that might present themselves
there's a higher risk and while they're
not necessarily an ideal solution there
are a couple of initiatives that we
could put in place to provide some level
of mitigation and I think the context of
the the roof scenario is a very extreme
earthquake event it's probably not your
your average earthquake event that would
likely to have an issue with the roof
but that yes if it was an extreme event
then they could there have been
identified some some hesitate the roof
off what while we're currently above
sixty seven percent of new building code
for this building and the and the
building was designed to take a heavy
roof one of the reasons for taking the
roof off there were two main reasons one
is it allows us with a lighter roof to
take out a lot of the upstairs
petitioning which would enable us to go
to a more open man environment without
the weight on top of it so that was one
of the drivers and the other as Rob
indicated and a severe event some of the
tiles coming loose presenter risk
entranceways to the building now and I
think it's that looks rubber saying this
relatively cheap options to minimize
that risk if we felt inclined to it but
at the moment that's not within the
scope of the work that's sitting here
but it could be a reasonably minor
property maintenance and type matter if
we so desired thank you
my question is about the roof can we
have a costing of just too much it would
be to to replace it roof because to me
that's far as I could see and very vital
for health and safety Rob do you want to
make any coming because we have had the
costings in a number of different ways
so we could bring that to to the meeting
I'm not sure whether it's in a forum
doing it in isolation to what was going
to be other works and so a lot of these
things have some fun activity in
relation to cost but I know that we have
got various estimates and so it may be
that there is something that we bring
back to the steering group as well
any thoughts Rob yeah we can certainly
see only have the information don't have
it to hand unfortunately but I would
seem like that would be appropriate to
bring back to the to the steering group
as as soon as we can get it to meet I'll
kiss the meeting with six point one for
just would make a couple of additions B
just hits the end subject to councils
final approval in D just EADS after
reference to include oversight
well render a service center
refurbishment and under appoints the
third to be council a consent overseen
you know secret council dokey
and speaking to it I appreciate the work
that's gone into it there's been a lot
of work over the last number of years
where we've gone from a better four
million dollar exercise up to a six and
then we hit some estimates that were eye
watering just post-christmas I think
anything in the current the most
important thing to me is that we make
the changes that we make address the
major deficiencies in the building and
that is the HVAC and the heating system
there's some internal work to be done if
the budget allows rather than what I
understand here it does allow for but
they'll need to be very clear that if
we're looking at the roof be prepared
for substantial money and not only
substantial money for the roof you've
then got to account for staff that might
be able to work in the building through
their times okay welcome hearing the
reflection make about it but the roof is
a fairly major piece of work and I think
you'll find that it's you know you'll be
pushing the budget up quite
substantially if that is the direction
of travel we've had advice from staff
that they feel that there are the
reduced amount is right I think it's
responsible through this period of time
and I I think as I've mentioned here the
work needs to go in to address the major
deficiencies we are we are approving two
hundred thousand dollars in the budget
to commence a broader look at the civic
precinct so before we commit major
expenditure on this building we need to
actually be of the view where we're
going in the future this we it that's
proposed just addresses the deficiencies
that are here now perhaps some carpet
maybe a little bit of paint we'll see
where that budget goes but the major
piece of working here is the heating and
ventilation part which is the critically
squeaked in some other and enhancements
so look I'm supportive of the budget as
it is I think and I think Jeff in the
team for coming back with something
that's perhaps a bit more politically
acceptable in the current climate
1000 million dollars is not something
that the public would accept from us at
the moment thus here under takes
essentials that we need to do so I am
supportive then seeing it again smokey
thank you thank you very much and thank
you for explaining the reason of the
roof but I still really personally feel
that our staff come first and of that
roof something happens with it and
someone gets seriously injured or killed
then it's not good on us at all just a
question when in terms of building code
rating what is the rating of this
building currently I think it is an
average rating of around about 87 Bhasin
I certainly take the point that
everything we need to do in this
building has to be for the health and
safety of our staff and the working
conditions that they experience we won't
keep good stuff and people hippy if we
do not look after them and we have a
responsibility is an employer to look
after their health and safety the
heating and ventilation system which
we've all experienced as shocking and it
has actually caused health issues and so
we have to fix that that's a given and
the other thing is the the housing of
the IT departments being mentioned
specifically I I cannot believe if we
took all of our summer days up there to
show them the Attic that our IT
department currently works and I think
they've been quite horrified so that
department needs a much more functional
workspace and they've been asking for it
for a long long time they've been
waiting for a very long time and I I
think that's an absolute essential and
in the governed budget but I did raise
the point about functionality of our IT
Network we've seen how important IT is
now in the current where
and I think it's absolutely critical
that there is review whether it comes
under this budget or whether it comes
under a future budget but we have to be
able to do our jobs we have to be able
to do them remotely we have to be able
to do them online and we have to be able
to do them in person and I think that
it's critical for the working of this
building and all the staff and the
elected members owner that their IT
functionality is totally up to speed I
know it's expensive and I know it's a
hard one to justify but we cannot do our
jobs without it these days it's now
actually become an essential rather than
a luxury so I'm fully supportive of the
budget and here the building is at a
high rating for earthquake prone I
understand that issues with the roof but
I as long as we are meeting the
responsibilities we have which is always
to be over the sixty-seven beseen for
our public buildings and we are more
than more than meeting their
responsibilities in their area and we
simply cannot justify the cost in the
current environment so I'm fully in
support of this recommendation seems to
me okay I don't disagree with the
audiovisual type of IT that we need to
that that we need to have we probably
needed to have it and before David 19
came along and I know that we're pretty
seriously argued at around the table
necessity now yes I think it's always
been in the see city it's just that we
were forced to do it immediately as
opposed to in a in a organized manner I
think that some of those things will
actually hit to the 10-year plain and
there will be a plan that comes from
this group that will that will go under
the 10-year plan and can be spread
appropriately across the budgets as they
as they're coming out to to do the
building up to the standard that's
required all that and I think that
that's the that's the direction we have
to take we've been forced to do that
there is there is no other way of
putting it
you know we have to as Jeff said and in
the words of past councillor Jordan cut
haircloth the
we have to do that so we're gonna have
to continue to do that
the audiovisual stuff is just just one
of those I mean one of the other ones
that are very interested in as we've had
stuff working it from home now for over
two months how many of those staff can
work at home three days a week one day a
week two days a week whatever that may
be what does that do to our accomodation
within the building to help people if
we're just taking I don't know picket
number because I don't know what it is
but ten staff members that can work it
work at home for one day a week what
does that do to our office space and
they're the sorts of equations that we
we now actually have some experience and
that we can put in to building a much
better plan I think for this building
and and making sure that it's it's safe
the right size and adequate for what we
want to do the roof look you can walk in
and out of any building with a roof
that's got tiles on it my own home has
seven tons with us cars sitting sitting
on top of it it's you know it's a
building material people still build in
concrete tiles today they still make
them so adequate I think that what mr.
thorn ed described an effective the
entrances are far more dangerous if
tiles are coming down than being inside
a building in fact are thinking fine
from a single storey building that the
there's actually a three percent chance
of being killed in an earthquake in a
single storey building no matter where
you are in double storey building only
about triples that there I'm not
suggesting that we put our lives and put
starves lives at risk I'm not doing that
but cost-wise sorry mitigation and cost
wise need to be able to meet somewhere
in the middle and if you get avital roof
come down particularly in an 87%
building it's going to have to shake a
hell of a lot for that to fall down so
you know it's just a caution I'm looking
at all those things and the right
measured manner to get to the point that
we need to be at and let's face it we
have now through being forced to do it's
Rico vat19 with with our budgets we
actually have time that we can work on
that and we need to take it and make
sure we do it properly
Thank You mr. I'm really in favor of the
direction that we're taking I was most
unhappy to think that we were going to
be 19 million up to nine or ten million
dollars on refurbishing this old
building is opposed to putting that
money into a much better facility that
will look after us and they distract for
the next 80 to 40 years this building is
old and together with the library money
that's been put aside as even a million
dollars it makes perfect sense that we
just do the necessities here now and
plan immediately well we have the staff
in this building that's not that
computers for them move very quickly
onto building something that will look
after the needs of the staff in the
community for the next 30 or 40 years so
I'm looking forward to being part of it
I'm not going there good points have all
been made there's no need to respond so
I'll put the recommendation all those in
favor please say aye
contrary to clear that carry thank you
thank you mr. Wolfe for women we've got
some pages 72 sorry yes counselor
concern yeah well well didn't appear to
be any debate familiar one about the
third one agreed with the recommendation
that's good so pages 72 to 80 to some
property and business support we've to
deal with those now while the wolf was
here so you've got your pages there page
I think obviously and there officer
recommendation we can talk about how the
projects been reduced the future plans
to be considered
as part of the preset review so we can
strengthen their answer that we provided
the year and this is the disagreement
page 73
page 74
[Music]
page 76 77 Cerebus it sorry do it
nothing there's just quite a few typos
on page 77 will they be picked up later
or shall I just oh I just hit a
suggested we change down the bottom of
page 77 where it says in relation to
futex as your observation is incorrect I
think it should be strong it should be
your information as in Crete it's not
simply observation page 7
eight 79 80 81 and 82 okay
openly in the white pages yep thank you
so we now come to the remaining report
which is 6.2 mr. Miller you're doing
your job I'll give you a minute mr. me
just checking we've covered 52 the red
zone
through to I may have missed it I'm
apologies but 52 3 to 59 63 through to
60 its regeneration so but it's you felt
it was covered thank you I just hidden
hidden or me been discussing these ones
sorry no that's right I just I I don't
remember the freedom camping one either
no no thank you
which pages are they pages 52 right okay
for the purpose of completeness well
between the pages page 52 53 54 55 yep
yeah Ivan that extensive and vicious
spray campaign we've done extensive
checking through green space and as far
as we're concerned well we know Council
did not do that that did not hit well it
might have happened but it didn't happen
from our in and we don't know if it did
happen who did it and I just I asked
grant because we didn't cover it
yesterday to just add bit in the council
room reply that this was not if this
happened at all it did not happen from
the council in and he's checking was
green space with them he came to see if
they know who did it or whatever I think
it's important to point out that we did
not we did not do that from Arin 5 56 57
58 okay and then we moved on to
see which we did deal with you sir which
was on the after house okay so I think
we are complete view mr. mill would come
to your report 6.2 pages 35 to 40 thank
you no thanks for smear the this report
basically provides an overview of all
the changes that have gone through the
budget since the draft in your plane we
yet
or consultation you've gone through some
of the the reports and made some changes
those changes are included within the
numbers that are presented here had some
context from the public last night
asking about other departments and where
their savings are and I've explained to
them that the reports that the counselor
received to date include a lot of
capital works which have been reef or
cast and so basically four point five of
the report actually provides some of the
global changes that have occurred right
throughout the accounts and where the
savings have been made so just outline
those again which the council are
probably aware of we've made the savings
right across the board and the reasons
for those changes are shown in section
three and they relate right across the
accounts so it's reducing the interest
rates under the new economic environment
so they've gone down from 4% to three
point seven we have made some staff cuts
from the budget in frozen all salaries
we've readjusted capital programs so the
capital program is 29 million of capital
programs have actually been forecasted
into the new 2021 year is a net of about
ten point eight million that have been
forecast out over the years so these are
savings
point three on those were
in the current year and we've made a
number of other changes such as the
inflation that we allowed through the
accounts through bill who we get the
economic forecast farm we have reduced
that down to zero in making sure that
staff will from little from those
budgets we have changed the training
budget so we've taken over 50% of our
training budgets out and effectively
just allowing for the Health and Safety
and staff training foot for those to be
to continue in in addition to that we've
made a number of other small savings
right across the board so a lot of those
actually come through the other
departments and make up their 3.2
million the one that's that I had to
report back to council honors confirming
the 1.5 covert loan that we are
recommending to council over ten years
and that's the 1.5 million was their
assessment early assessment as shown on
and four point six of the report which
is the 1.4 million DIA such a little bit
lighter than that
we have made provision for the recovery
plane and that's showing the new as well
which makes that neat position of 2.2
and we've talked about the provision for
what happens to a consenting and so
forth but the but all the budgets have
been adjusted to allow for the the new
environment and there's the result of
some of the changes in four point eight
of the report we it indicates what the
into the areas will be adjusted to if we
were to it adopter the one point five
which is recommended in the report and
probably wouldn't
coming any further that but take the
risk that the report has been real epic
taking questions Thank You mr. mell
any questions Cass Williams yes and I've
asked for a report on how that covert
loan is being spent
will we get a breakdown of the costs
associated with that break the end of
that loan basically a 4.6 of the report
gives a breakdown of of all the areas
where we haven't made an assessment of
what the expenditure would be to 30th of
June so for instance the aquatic centers
the earth the neat that the net loss
that we were expecting on the budgeted
amount as the 206,000 so that takes any
income losses any expenses its expenses
in that account to the theater Joan
so as you run down that list there that
is the total amount that makes up that
1.5 it's just now one point 404 million
dollars that were expecting to be lower
than our budgeted amount to the theeth
of June the accounts that have been
presented to the council now take into
effect the changes that were expecting
from 1 July 2013 2021 the additional
amount that we can't determine on the
stage is the recovery provision which
the council's need to adopt and these
further reports to be brought to the
council that confirms it figure whatever
their figure is it would be an
adjustment to that line and therefore
the rates would be increased or
decreased depending on what the recovery
the actual covering amount would be and
we can bring that back in the 18th of
June whether it's available for the
impetus this is a provision that we're
making at this stage just
to that it's probably going to be July
before you get a sense of what we are
anticipating our recovery costs or what
or the costs that might be associated
with the actions and that obviously
depends on what you decide
and also what actually happens out there
and we don't know so at the moment we've
got a placeholder there of five hundred
thousand to anticipate that if through
the course of this next year you felt
that more than that needed to be applied
then that would probably when we come to
next year's LTP adjust what this covert
loan requirement would be beyond that
next year so that would have a rate
effect from next year if during the
course of this year you felt more needed
to be applied alternately if none of
that needed to be applied then that
would see the amount go down although
realistically I'm not seeing you in that
space but there were obviously a high
degree of uncertainty q any further
questions we've got a recommendation I'm
prepared to move the recommendation as
the recipient accounts so their concern
just in speaking to it can I can I just
start by saying I'd like to acknowledge
all the hard work of staff that's gone
into the preparation of the budget it's
been it's been a very difficult time to
be considering this whilst we've been
unlocked down for a large portion of
that staff of week particularly heard
from their homes and trying
circumstances themselves to get us to
this point here a number of workshops
with colleagues to get an appreciation
of the challenges that we face and also
the level of rate increase that's being
talked of was something that was
signaled to us when we when we hit the
zoom call recently just to see if there
was something
degree of travel was where we were
comfortable with where that was hitting
and I didn't hear at that time a major
concern but I know that some would like
it lower and in bits it's natural but I
think where we've landed here is a
responsible position I particularly like
to acknowledge the extent leadership of
both our chief executive finance manager
all our senior managers in all the staff
that come under there they've I think
presented us a budget that as a
mentioned before is responsible it means
it recognises the hardship that is and
we're starting to see recognized in our
community and there needs to be a
balance between a central service
delivery and investment to support our
community in the recovery of our
district at this time is his been
mentioned a few times throughout the
course of this next year's long term
plan as we there will be considerable
challenge for this council and preparing
a plane at that point that strikes the
balance between community investment and
also rates affordability as something
that will be at the forefront of our
minds as we go through these what is
presented here is what is we've talked
about as what is known now and as we
work with their community and partners
on an economic and social recovery plan
they may need to be changes and we may
need to be a bit more flexible and
nimble in having the the ability of the
recovery provision for then I think it's
a responsible position for us to
consider to give that flexibility
because we don't I'm saying so quite
logic we don't know what we don't know
and we don't end the in occasionally I'm
getting a message from a number of
people who are finding it really trying
and difficult a lot of their businesses
are really using and motels one one
example with the occupants he's down
considerably it's a difficult time and
we're not some of the it's being masked
at the moment by the wage subsidy and
when they when they
concludes we will then know actually we
are with and how we're fearing in that
space but at the moment the most
important thing is we signal to our
community that we've listened which we
have and that we're sending and miss a
responsible message that strikes the
right balance so I ask you to support
mr. Mel woods report which signals the
council's direction can straight consent
Thank You mr. Mia begin to the star folk
I echo the the remarks that you've made
I also want to acknowledge my colleagues
around this table in certainly demeanor
in which these discussions have been
held in certainly discussions even the
outside this room about submissions and
all of those things that have come and I
think everybody has the impetus
absolutely required and in the situation
that we're in with with covert being
being about in thank everyone of you for
that as well as the staff as I mentioned
I've grappled with the indications of
1.5% in where we've gone council Blakey
oh I've had some reasonably
philosophical question discussions
around should we be it more I mean a lot
of councillors have mentioned such thing
as a bear wave and it deeply concerned
me about what happens next year and the
year after and the reason I'm absolutely
prepared to second this in supporter
there's the fact that lucky I don't know
if you use the word lucky but we're
lucky that that next year is LTP and we
have the ability to either drop up
spread change meet the submissions that
are coming forward to us in the light of
a 10-year budget and that's the reason
that I'm fully supportive of the 11.5
percent rise if we'd been further out
from the LTP I'm not convinced in my own
mind that's where I
be-because I think the penalties to our
ratepayers in the future would could be
a lot higher and a lot more disastrous
because there are things that you still
have to do and just pushing them forward
is not going to be the answer to getting
things done and the other one of course
is the fact that you need to stimulate
an economy and while that is
government's responsibility it is also
the responsibility of local government
to make sure we are possible that those
local contracts and things that we have
and our capital projects can be pushed
out there to give local people work and
make sure that we have an economy that's
sustainable I think this is responsible
I think it's something that we have to
do in in your mr. mayor you're
absolutely right and the fact that we
haven't seen yet the consequences of
closing down for our economy for
basically for six weeks they will come
in the future and it will it will take a
toll that none of us want to see but
we'll have to deal with so I think this
is responsible and I think that it is
the way to go but my writing factor on
that is the reason that I think that is
that we have a ten year plan that we
have to deal with next year and can
actually sort out some of those future
rises and stop a Bauer way of coming I
think in the way of percentages so we
will have to be very disciplined in that
I have no problem with that that's the
way they have to be but also just a wee
warning to our community you will also
have to be very disciplined and what it
is you ask this council to do in the
next ten years if we are going to make
sure that we have fiscal responsibility
within our communities but still have a
progressive community council a concern
counts nieces council Redmond followed
by council flaky and council Williams
Thank You mr. Mia I'd like to
congratulate the staff on the work
they've carried out with the budgets
under the Local Government Act we have a
duty in terms of financial management to
promote the current and future interests
of our community and whilst I was happy
with the proposed increase of 4% pre
Kovan these the use that you were done
present unprecedented circumstances have
changed the world for us and I
originally signaled something up to 2%
I don't think a zero rates and Crais
actually solves the problem it just
postponed some of the issues for the
future I'm very pleased at 1.5% I think
that as a balanced budget we've
reflected the needs of the community
with the new financial circumstances the
ratepayers a lot of breakers find
themselves in there is financial
hardship and the wider community a
survey entire pooi recently disclosed
that 50% of parents of a particular
skull had been unpacked and either by
redundancy loss of income or reduced
hours so the effect out there is very
significant and on the front page of the
priest this morning it was pretty somber
statistics as to what's happening the
only good part of Vedas that was that
survey was carried out while we're under
level 4 and of course most people
couldn't work and we're all confined to
our barracks at home so I'm hoping under
the more lenient levels that the result
may become slightly well hopefully much
better I agree that the real effects of
covent are still suppressed and they're
going to be suppressed until after the
election I suspect with wage subsidies
another
I won't say helicopter payments but with
other our payments getting pumped into
the wider community
so in all I think we've actually
balanced two competing things it's been
a difficult job because there are a lot
of works that have been deferred for a
year or two it would have been nice to
have those works done in this coming
financial year but we've end I think
we're all pretty United and that and
we've made some very good decisions not
easy decisions and hopefully the
community will accept what we've done
and I believe we're acting in the best
interests overall so I support the
motion yeah excellent excellent job from
Jeff and Jim I have no problem
whatsoever with it my slight concern is
around the focus of the focus in who
we're targeting the unemployment factor
is probably in this if we go somewhere
between five and ten percent we're
looking at the high hundreds of people
and unemployed in financial crisis in
our area six seven eight hundred people
something like that what we've done the
way we've done it by reducing from four
percent rise to 1.5 is thrown a blanket
right across everybody including a whole
lot of people who don't actually need it
when I say need a rate reduction rate
rise reduction I mean need as opposed to
want because everybody always wants one
but I'm just a little bit concerned that
we're not we're not we're not focusing
on the on the people enough who are
going to be in crisis and if we if we
took our 1.5 percent rise is mooted and
put it up to two percent that is fifty
cents a week per person per average rate
payer oh I apologize for using that
dreadful mythical average rate payer
thing but you sort of have to and for
purposes of discussion
so I look upon it as a sort of a giver
little page you know we don't want to be
mother knows best but if you've got 50
cents in your pocket what are you gonna
do with it every ten weeks you're going
to say I've got five dollars I can do
something useful with us if we got 50
cents per ratepayer per week extra by
going to say 2% that give what would
give us about three hundred and fifty
thousand dollars in a year to add to
Jim's 500 which gives us that which
boosts our fighting fund as the other
speakers have said I worry a lot about
where we'll be in 6 to 12 months you
know just in just throwing your billions
around and no doubt pre-election she'll
scatter them around like confetti but
after that when it's all gone and we're
and we're in end of this calendar year
or into the next year I worry we all
know this council is a very very high
emphasis on the welfare of our people
and we make a big thing of it and we are
the gold standard amongst councils of
New Zealand I venture to say in that
regard the funding is going to dry up
we've seen it already the rat is drying
up the donations from businesses are
drying up I worry a lot that we will run
out of funding in 6 to 12 months no
matter what we do we're gonna get flack
for this so I mean there's no right or
wrong I'm really really concealed there
we're gonna get flack for this but I
mean you know being a councillor isn't a
popularity contest we're gonna get flack
whatever we do so so suck it up you know
last year we asked the ratepayers to
give us $2 a week each forever for to
pay for our stadium so you know you just
put that alongside asking them for 50
cents a week each for a year to help
those in desperate need we have a we
have a on the continuity continuum of of
perception at one end we have our public
relations thing we have our our yeah PA
what the public think and what we have
to do the political the politics of it
and I get there and at the other end we
have the hey we need the money to do
stuff and I think on that scale
we're just a little bit too far towards
the PR end and not enough towards the
hey we need more money in so I just
throw that into the pot thank you do you
counsel Williams yes well I think it's
an a good effort to get down to the 1.5
and this is a good enough effort I
personally believe it's not a good
enough if it and I'll explain it why my
reasoning was pushing things out as
don't gonna hurt and their future years
coming we need in the next two years as
we are some of the business people
around the town's ratepayers we and the
towns are going to start suffering but
pushing things out all we're doing is
sliding the the movement of the the
money that they're gonna have to pay
later on I would have liked to have seen
more efficiencies with this council and
the way we do things and that's where I
think we've been letting and getting
this budget then a part of this drop is
just because solely of interest rates
gone down
we've got huge debt and this council so
I believe the figure is around 700 odd
thousand dollars we're gonna save just
on interest rate drop well that would
have been a natural effect anyway young
without us hammering on saying we've
dropped was down such machines
businesses in the area are suffering
near they actually been suffering before
the scope of thing happened here it's
going to make it worse that probably got
the biggest percentage of square meters
of rates we charge a lot of them in the
area and down and the other one's gonna
be suffering they're also the people an
employee of a lot of our people around
the area as well and it's a big flow on
effect and we have got him in buildings
and Waimakariri
at the moment the people can't rent
that's a bit of a worry there's no
stimulus there to improve the helping
the business people in the air
it's just we need to cut here cloth to
suit and we've done a good job of
getting some of the expenses down but I
don't think we've actually gone far
enough and we need to look more into the
efficiencies of the way this council's
being run
thank you yes I think when we look at
the budget and where we started and
where we've come from the important
thing is to work out why we do this
process why do we do the annual clean
process and the key reason is to listen
to the submissions from our community
and I believe what we've done in this
achieved in this budget from going down
from a four percent rise to a 1.5 we
have listened to the submissions just
about every community board made the
point to us that they wanted to see us
reduce the rate race to help people in
their communities and that covers the
whole district covered 19 has given us
an opportunity as well as being very
hard it's helped us review what's really
important to us and and you noticed that
it wasn't the fact that you could go on
holiday or anything like that it was
actually the people it was the fact that
you could get together with people for a
while you couldn't get together with
people and so the community side was
absolutely critical and it's gonna be
really interesting because this year
will be a test for us it's a reduction
in the level of service and many areas
and that will be a test to see as is
that important to us it'll be really
good for our ratepayers to look at what
we're doing to reduce levels of service
to make this saving and say is this
acceptable to our community are these
areas areas we could make view the
savings are those areas that actually it
doesn't work if we cut it to this level
we're a growing district so to say that
we cannot progress things in a growing
district means the level of service will
drop so if we were to cut further back
than 1.5 percent I think the level would
drop below which people would be
comfortable with remember that the wage
subsidies that are going out at the
moment are providing a bit of an
artificial buffer for it for people the
people who are affected and are taking
those wage subsidies have not felt the
full pain yet and they will feel it next
year and in the coming years so what
we've done to them today and may if this
what recommendation goes through which I
hope it will as we've shown
responsibility in response to
submissions from our community and I
just would like to make one plea to our
community and the level of service drop
is going to be difficult for staff they
like looking after the community on
behalf of ratepayers they want to do the
best possible job but they are going to
have less resources this year so my
final message to our ratepayers as we've
done our best we've got it down as far
as we can without damaging the need to
grow and thus district and when you
notice some of these levels of services
and some of these changes coming through
please be kind remember that's the most
important thing look after our people
and be kind thank you any further
speakers just some right of reply
knowledge the remarks councillor and
concern made I should have recognized
those in my comments but implied I think
as that the spirit in which we've all
had discussions as colleagues I think
we've all worked really well together
through this exercise working with our
staff to identify change changes in the
budget and also the community boards as
well as is councillor Barnett mentioned
they've been very understanding through
this exercise they've offered up savings
themselves and their own budgets so
that's I think that's the true spirit of
partnership and which we've entered and
understanding through a very difficult
time for our community in for our
council the challenge will definitely be
in out years as we've all observed
we've all got a lot of work to do in the
space so if we think it's going to be
business as usual coming into the long
term clean the challenger's has been
observed as to make sure that we very
clear about the sort of service that we
expect going forward and how we're going
to afford it if it's agreed today at 1.5
there will be an X expectation in our
community that the risers don't get too
far up and other years so we're going to
have some challenges in that area
councillor Williams mentioned looking
for more efficiencies absolutely we've
all got to always be vigilant for
efficiencies and I really look forward
to your suggestions counselor Williams
in that space as well I've certainly got
an open mind look forward to the ideas
that we've all got here and how we can
make savings and efficiency so bring
them on because that's what it's all
about this we go into the long term plan
I don't need to say anymore I just hope
that you all will support of the
recommendations because there's been a
lot of work he's gone into a workshop
bias or signaled clearly by our staff in
you know if we were to reduce further or
to go out it's always a decision for
this body but I think we've all shown
that we are signalling this level of
comfort so I'm hoping your support this
degree of that we're indicating in this
in this budget so the recommendation all
those in favor please say aye
contrary are the clear they're carried
would you like your okay that's carried
thank you everyone
right
consider these submissions I've got no
questions no age in general business a
next meeting will be at 3:15 on Tuesday
the 16th of June to a dot sorry for this
for this part we've got a council
meeting next week and their briefing -
follows you're not quite off the hook
you because I just before I close I just
like to think all staff that have done
supported us the last few days and the
lead-up to the sixer sighs we've hits
Syrah has put a lot of time and making
sure were for your governance team that
we supported to get us into this forum
eithne mention earth at the start was
about to meet you in thanks to Syrah Tia
in all their governance team that have
been with us throughout the last few
days particularly to Helene as well
appreciate all the work and support you
give as well to Jeff and German who've
been here through the majority of the
time all the time and also our senior
managers and the line managers that have
come and that supported and as I mention
in my comments thanks to you all for the
spirit in which we've had a good
conversation a really good deliberation
making I think look there's been a
couple of things that could have been
done a little smooth more smoothly
through this period so that I'm a
reflective sort of person I would
welcome any feedback that you have we
were a couple items Easter day that
could have gone a little smoother and I
I'm certainly would like to reflect on
it with the staff and we do generally
have a debrief after this so after the C
exercise which counts the wards involved
and as well so if you have any comments
or feedback please get them victim e in
the next over the next couple of days by
the start of next week would be good and
I'd like to just take those forward so
we can any learnings from this would be
helpful so we can make sure any Express
has even better
thank you view on all the clear
animation Christ
[Music]
you